- [Voiceover] You look at a community
that is in a given habitat,
a natural question is to say,
well, has that community
always been that way?
Has it always been there?
Was there a time where maybe
there was no life there?
And the answer is, well, yes,
the communities do change over time,
and there is some initial period
where there might not be
any life in that habitat,
and then life slowly colonizes it,
and the makeup of that
life will change over time,
the makeup of that community.
And this general idea is
called ecological succession.
Ecological succession.
And folks will often talk about
the different types of
ecological succession,
splitting it up into primary
and so primary is when
you start with no life,
because you really have a new habitat,
and then slowly life colonizes it.
And the best example of that,
or one of the best examples of that
is when new land forms due to lava flows.
There are pictures from Hawaii,
where new land is forming
as this lava hardens.
And, at first, there is,
when it's molten lava,
there's no life there, then it hardens,
and slowly, basic life,
or life in general,
will start to colonize that lava rock.
And some of it you won't be
able to see with your naked eye,
it would be microbes,
and some of it you could see,
it could be simple ferns
and plants like that,
and these are often called
the pioneer species.
But what they often do
is make that environment
more suitable for other types of life.
So they might slowly break down that rock.
As they die, along with
the broken down rock
that also gets eroded from the water
and the air and the rain,
it starts to make soil and
conditions more suitable
for other types of species.
And these pioneer species,
they don't even have to
just be plants and microbes.
I was just reading an
article about how in Hawaii,
humans want to get that land
because it's beachfront property.
Or the beach might not
have formally formed
in the traditional sense, but
you have ocean view property.
So humans might be some of
the first pioneer species
who might wanna be out on that land.
And that new land doesn't
just form from lava flows.
There are other examples
of new habitats forming.
So right here, we have pictures
of a new habitat forming
because of the retreat of glaciers.
When the glaciers were
covering up these rocks,
you didn't have life on them.
But as the glacier
retreats right over here,
you see things like these mosses
and other types of pioneer
species starting to colonize.
And over time, they're going to make it
more and more suitable for
other types of species.
So that's primary succession.
Another situation is when you
have secondary succession.
And there's many different ways
you could have secondary succession.
One of the most cited examples
is when you have some type of a disaster.
And so this right over here,
this is a picture of a fire,
so here, we're talking
'bout secondary succession,
where you had a community,
but then you have a fire,
and so that fire might wipe
out a lot of the community.
And then it creates space
for other things to form.
So after you have a fire,
the forest might look something like this,
and then, notice, you have
species that start to colonize
where a lot of other
species might have died
or died during the fire.
And sometimes, after this
disaster of some kind,
you might get back to the
same type of community
that you had before the disaster,
but sometimes, it could be
a completely different one,
that the communities don't come about
in exactly the same way.
So the general idea is
communities change over time,
we have ecological succession.
There are times where
there's no community,
and then they come in,
that's primary succession.
And then, you have times where you have
disasters of some kind
that could change the
environment in some ways,
and it could change the
makeup of that community.
And things don't have to be as dramatic
as new land formation because of lava
or because of forest fires
or even glaciers retreating.
It could because of a disease,
or it could just be because
a new species gets introduced somehow
that changes the makeup,
changes the competition,
the predatory, the various,
the symbiotic dynamics
within that community.